we can all have a bad night of sleep and
that's perfectly normal
but how can we try to improve both the
quantity and the quality of our sleep
[Music]
here are six scientifically grounded
tips for better sleep the first tip is
regularity go to bed at the same time
and wake up at the same time regularity
is king and it will actually anchor your
sleep and improve both the quantity and
the quality no matter whether it's the
weekday or the weekend or even if you've
had a bad night of sleep and the reason
is because deep within your brain you
actually have a master 24-hour clock it
expects regularity and works best under
conditions of regularity including the
control of your sleep wake schedule many
of us use an alarm to wake up but very
few of us use a tibetal arm and that's
something that can be helpful the next
tip is temperature keep it cool it turns
out that your brain and your body need
to drop their core temperature by about
one degree celsius or around two to
three degrees fahrenheit in order to
initiate sleep and then to stay asleep
and this is the reason that you will
always find it easier to fall asleep in
a room that's too cold than too hot so
the current recommendation is to aim for
a bedroom temperature of around about 65
degrees fahrenheit or a little over 18
degrees celsius it sounds cold but cold
it must be the next tip
is darkness
we are a dark deprived society and in
fact we need darkness specifically in
the evening to trigger the release of a
hormone called melatonin a melatonin
helps regulate the healthy timing of our
sleep in the last hour before bed try to
stay away from all of those computer
screens and tablets and phones dim down
half the lights in your house you'd
actually be quite surprised at how
sleepy that can make you feel if you'd
like you can wear an eye mask or you can
have blackout shades and that will help
best regulate that critical sleep
hormone of melatonin the next tip is
walk it out don't stay in bed awake for
long periods of time
and the general rule of thumb is if
you've been trying to fall asleep and
it's been 25 minutes or so or you've
woken up and you can't get back to sleep
after 25 minutes the recommendation is
to get out of bed and go and do
something different and the reason is
because your brain is an incredibly
associative device the brain has learned
the association that the bed is this
trigger of wakefulness and we need to
break that association and by getting
out of bed you can go and do something
else only return to bed when you're
sleepy and in that way gradually your
brain will relearn the association that
your bed is this place
of sound and consistent sleep the fifth
tip is something that we've actually
already spoken about in detail in this
series which is the impact of alcohol
and caffeine so a good rule of thumb
here is to try to stay away from
caffeine in the afternoon and in the
evening and certainly try not to go to
bed too tipsy the final tip have a wind
down routine i think many of us in the
modern world we expect to be able to
dive into bed at night switch off the
light and we think that sleep is also
just like a light switch that we should
immediately be able to fall asleep well
unfortunately sleep isn't quite like
that for most of us
sleep as a physiological process is much
more similar to landing a plane
it takes time for your brain to
gradually descend down onto the firm
bedrock of good sleep in the last 20
minutes before bed or the last half an
hour even the last hour disengage from
your computer and your phone and try to
do something relaxing find out whatever
works for you and when you have found it
stick to that routine
the last thing i should note is that if
you are suffering from a sleep disorder
for example from insomnia or sleep apnea
then these tips aren't necessarily going
to help you if i was your sports coach i
could give you all of these tips to
improve your performance but if you have
a broken ankle it's not going to make a
difference we have to treat the broken
ankle first before we can get back to
improving the quality of your
performance and it's the same way with
sleep so if you think you have a sleep
disorder just go and speak with your
doctor that's the best piece of advice
where do we stand then in all of this
conversation about sleep
well i think the evidence is clear
we can think of sleep almost like a life
support system in fact some may even
call sleep a superpower